who's a cast member you'd be okay never
having to interact with again hi Arianna
hi brace you're officially a cocktail
book author I am and it's a hit it's a
hit the moment you met drink for us what
are we yes this is the berry margarita
made with blackberries basil tequila
obviously Cointreau and agave nectar
simple simple will gin delicious Cheers
I love a midday cocktail moment at work
yeah at work at work for Billy is
technically yeah that's true
I'm gonna make a little rule if any time
during the interview you don't want to
answer a question you gotta take a sip
of that okay yeah it's a drinking game
we're kind of in the thick of season
eight already yeah things got off to a
roaring start don't you think what about
it so far I feel good I feel like you
never really know everything happening
happened so fast on our show you never
really know like what you're gonna get
even though you lived it and then we
have these kind of big blowup moments
that sometimes come out of nowhere
yeah often episode where that happen yes
[Music]
isn't about you okay sure saucy that was
extremely Ottawa what did you make of
the big Tom and Stassi blow-up in
everything yeah well I do feel like I
need to make very clear that I told him
do not contact her whatsoever the night
before you know kind of knew how that
was gonna go but then I went to bed and
did his own thing while he was so in the
wrong for sending that text message I
felt like things escalated very quickly
I look like I'm silent silent but then
it's like I'm laughing and I never got
to say this I was laughing because
they're like conspiracy theory of the
jealousy thing I was just thought was so
insane you know we were so excited for
her book to do well and we had
conversations with our publisher about
how that is such a good thing for us
yeah so even if we didn't love and care
about her even on the most selfish level
it's just like that's insane it does
look like this is not a thing that is
living in just that one episode yeah
well I can't tell you that I'd have to
kill you yeah no unfortunately I think
that when emotions are running high it's
very hard for two people to come to an
understanding you and Stassi have worked
for years to get to a place where you're
good yes did this impact your
relationship with her at all I think
that there's definitely some fallout
that you'll see but again I think that
it's important to realize that two
people who are in a relationship are two
different people who have different
perspectives and point of view points of
view on mostly everything and I am my
own person and I have very strong
opinions of my own there we go but I
find it so interesting how the
Vanderpump rules fans it's like they're
detectives they are constantly looking
at everybody's social media figuring out
who was where why they weren't invited
right there was recently a
small girls trip people made a big deal
out of it that you and scheana and
Kristen weren't there yeah I mean I
don't know I didn't know they were going
on a trip that being said I think it's
fine I you know my pinned tweet on my
Twitter is that I want to be invited
even though I'm probably not gonna go so
maybe invite me next time but at the
same time I don't know that I could have
gone okay we know stassi's being
selective with her wedding invites yes
do you know if you're gonna get an
invite to that as far as I know I don't
think invitations have been sent out
okay so you're enough to TBD on that TBD
on that and maybe TBD on if you'll want
to accept that invitation accepted it's
a lot to ask of somebody Emily is
wonderful no I
we know wedding not happening for you
not even gonna go there but you did do a
big adult thing about a house yeah which
is kind of like you're in Toms listen we
got that we got a notary we we basically
sign that in blood you know weird we are
in it to win it we have a 30-year
mortgage together and that's commitment
we have a joint bank account oh okay
that's like like yeah that's very
committed there's no question of our
commitment to each other I gotta say are
we at least at a place now where
Schwartz isn't having to bring a pop you
have so many chairs okay yes so many
beautiful chairs because I was another
thing that kind of blew up on social
media people going after you guys for
not I just want to know when did
everybody cut become such snobs about
everything you know it's like you're not
coming over
why do you care especially it's like you
guys had to sit through years of people
critiquing that apartment you're living
in right so like I want to get good for
my house what's the bar set up like you
got to cocktail experts in the house
together yeah so tom is building a fully
functioning one-of-a-kind top-notch bar
in our house okay I think he he's
working on maybe getting nikoline to
designer going that far
yeah like Elaine and Elaine Elaine his
wife yes Elaine Elaine let's get back
into what's happen
on the show I'm shook it there's an
arrest moment or police car moment
that's coming up mm-hmm that a little
birdie or maybe a dog with alopecia
domain is maybe not what it looks like
yeah I'm feel like beyond that if I tell
you anymore to just ruin everything
but was it a surprise to you absolutely
okay yes I have had like a fear of law
enforcement and you know when you're
getting that like fight-or-flight right
you know so it is very scary for me
that whole moment I'd wanna unpack that
but I feel like that's maybe something
for your therapist it's definitely
something for my therapist is that sound
yeah okay moving on we do see in the in
line with kind of therapy and almost
using the show as therapy you're sharing
a lot this season I I think I need to be
manic kiba's a YouTube for us is that
are you feeling happen for a very long
time what has it been like to kind of
start having that conversation in the
public it's definitely not easy but I
feel like once you start talking about
something it's somehow makes it easier I
just feel like you know we need to be
having those conversations because I
don't like the idea that people feel bad
talking about it nobody should feel bad
talking about it it doesn't define
Sheena's divorce doesn't define her I'm
divorced I don't know if you know that
no ideal doesn't define me my depression
does not define me I used to say I
suffer from and now I say I live with
because I have depression but I am
living so this season we're seeing you
at some lows how are you doing right now
oh well right now I feel like I'm doing
great
today is a really good day I feel really
good about today fall great yesterday
you know I just feel like I take I have
to start training myself
take things day by day and live in the
moment of now a little bit better and
feed my creative spirit and do things to
take care of myself in my brain
this past summer was very very rough for
me and for a lot of reasons which is
crazy because on the whole the year of
2019 was just like frickin awesome
it's just it's crazy but I do feel like
I am in a really good place right now
putting the work in and hopefully next
summer will be better what's been the
response like from the viewers of you
having that open dialog there's been a
lot of people who have come and said
that they have gone through similar
things and so what's funny is that those
people will say that I've helped them by
being open but they don't realize that
they're helping me so much by making me
feel like I'm not alone validating it's
validating and it also feels like
there's like support in within this
community of the viewers of our show on
the flip side of this some of the
feedback from that very specific scene
where this was brought up was people
notice your hair magically grew for
certain portions like a lot of biotin
it's working overtime at that moment
explain kind of what that is and why
it's not a big deal yeah so it's just
the nature of you know production and
filming is that you know we are having a
very real conversation in both instances
but you know sometimes something doesn't
work a light light goes out or an audio
thing goes out and it they didn't catch
it so and it's no stretch for me to talk
about depression or my life or things
like that any given day for cardless of
my healing I mean it's just you know the
nature of what we can't be wearing body
cams and you know naming and things have
to just it doesn't make the conversation
you had any less real it doesn't make
the show any less real no we saw you and
Lisa it was that same much-talked-about
scene but also having to kind of repair
that relationship after you being once
again honest and open when some
you've employed for 10 years starts
talking frankly I'm kind of mystified as
to why you would want to come back here
where do things stand with you and Lisa
today I feel like that as as difficult
as that time in our relationship was I
feel like it was the best thing for our
relationship because we are have gotten
to a place now if we are so honest and
open with each other and that's the
place that I never really thought I
would even get to with Lisa because we
had had this like employer-employee kind
of gap and so I feel like I see her a
lot differently to know Lisa as a person
and get to know her on that level and be
able to share things about me with her
as well feels it feels really good
I feel like a good thing that to come
out of her leaving housewives is we're
getting some of those deeper scenes and
those conversations now on Vanderpump
rules and so yeah well I feel like
something that maybe and I'm speculating
here but something that maybe she got
from that whole experience was that we
on Vanderpump rules
actually we do love her and we do
support her and maybe we are people she
could see as future friends instead of
people who she can't trust or she
doesn't feel good around I like that
thought all right now I have some more
dialed in questions that I feel like
you'll be drinking more okay take a
bracer sip okay mm-hmm in the group of
Vanderpump rules who's a cast member
you'd be okay never having to interact
with again Jax obviously okay yeah I'd
be okay with that why though I just
don't think he's a nice person you know
he when I watch happens live and poked
at you and yeah I just yeah I just think
he says a lot of mean things about a lot
of people and a lot of those people are
strangers it just sigh you know so I I
haven't interacted with him in a very
long time actually and I'd be okay with
that as long as I still get to see
Brittney
okay that's the one thing I really love
that's tricky that is true kind of a
pair yeah alright who is someone in the
group that you feel like you owe an
apology to Katie why I just love her so
much and I feel like sometimes we end up
on opposite sides of an issue that
largely might not have to do either with
both of us directly and I just I love
her and I I don't know I just want her
to be happy okay maybe you won't drink
during this what do you think about
scheana becoming season one Stassi and
hazing Dana at Sur I think that there is
a lot more to that that you know will
not be talked about on the show
I love scheana very dearly but I love
Dana a whole whole lot she's one of my
closest friends at this point and so
honestly watching them Duke it out was
really funny and entertaining for me
like I said on the show you know you
either die the hero live long enough to
become the villain and Sheena's doing it
Stassi she's soon to get married yeah
lalla and Randall will get married soon
Jackson Brittany just got married so of
those three whose marriage do you see
lasting the longest yeah I'm gonna drink
because I feel like they're all gonna
last
okay that's nice let's say you can't go
into a marriage thinking like there's
gonna be an end that's true and as their
friend that would be really [ __ ] up
last season we learned about an
unexpected hookup what's another
Vanderpump rules related hookup we might
be surprised to know about oh I feel
like I feel like at this point they're
all out there okay it's all the next
feelings it's all been exposed like that
was the last like cross Bravo Liberty
hookup oh uh there's definitely been
some cross Bravo Liberty hook up with
like art art cast and like other cast
but you're not going but I heard about
had you heard about well I feel like it
would be I feel like it would be so you
know messed up of me to put someone
else's drink yeah every whenever people
from our show come ask every single one
of them until one of them until one of
them was like it was me that's what you
gotta do okay mm-hmm but there's
something to that well you tell me now
what person but maybe what show somebody
else's on yeah southern charm actually
well and obviously Sheena and Carl made
out or whatever
alright to wrap up these styled
questions a classic and never have I
ever
okay what is the wildest place you and
Tom I've ever hooked up Oh in the back
of his Honda City seven Honda Civic
parked you know like you know oh my god
you know like Hollywood and LaBrea
yeah and like there's there's like an
alley between a parking garage and like
so and it was raining very specific yes
right about that little romantic little
worried it's on a security camera
somewhere oh oh because I feel like
everything is on security care right but
it's like how long ago was this log of
the statute of limitations that's what
it gets dumped after a period of time
what's up there's still a lot of season
left to watch what are you most excited
for what still to come I'm really
excited for Tom Sandoval's birthday
party the my it you and Tom are in like
full old man make oh no that's in Miami
for during the bachelor that's coming
baby that's coming up soon that I'm very
excited to see that the Tom Sandoval's
birthday Jackson's birthday was a really
fun one
and then some fun pool party stuff
towards the end okay on the flip side
anything you're dreading having to I'm
dreading literally the entirety of the
next three weeks why come on like good
stuff go down on the bachelor
bachelorette trip stuff just continually
continually keeps going down good I walk
around on eggshells and Jax does
whatever the [ __ ] he wants
why are you trying to hurt somebody like
this it's kind of disturbing well cheers
to that
Cheers yeah like everything thank you
you can like if your mom could hold that
in her hands is very cool it's very cool
and she's got a nice little dedication
in there too Cheers yes Cheers
let's stay fancy guys
[Music]